d'accord sur ce qu'on avait rien il n'ya
rien n'a été fait dans les dernières
années la diversité c'était quand même
un passé la selas probablement la seule
chose que les sept meilleures juste ou
bordeaux
c'était sympa mais juste le ferait
passer les partenaires jusqu'au bout la
sélection ne va rien changer aux
problèmes de l'enseignement supérieur
français pourquoi pas ce que c'est
exactement ce que vous disiez tout à
l'heure du thé il faut changer le bac il
faut un système de fautes
d'apprentissage et de formation et de
formation et doute de formation
universitaire qui soit aussi bon si vous
voulez c'est pourquoi est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde se
précipite à l'université 1 c'est parce
qu'il n'ya pas de place dans les grandes
écoles et deux c'est parce que personne
ne veut aller dans un homme dans
l'apprentissage formation
professionnelle qui sont considérés en
france comme des voies de garage vous
avez un une opr un auteur suisse
françois garçon qui a écrit un excellent
l'islam d'apprentissage suisse qui
explique cette idée est une apprentie
sidina et surtout il vit en suisse mi
juin c'est bien l'idée en suisse notre
gouvernement nous dit fait
l'apprentissage fait il faut que vos
enfants face à l'apprentissage et tout
le monde les croise que la moitié du
gouvernement est issu de l'apprentissage
en france vous avez des énarques des
polytechniciens qui vous dit fait
l'apprentissage regarder mes enfants
vont à normal vont ainsi en fin de
mandat sur ce